[Applaudissements]
ça dure je suis désolé parce que je
trouve moi je suis assez d'accord et que
je regarde toujours les coiffures oif en
terre marque en premier oui au premier
jour là la tourmente je suis comme lui
un premier promet que je regarde avant
la clôture oui mais à côté de ça j'avais
une super coiffure avant d'arriver
maintenant vraiment génial et m'a dit
date et coiffage là
[Applaudissements]
je le connais il te connais c'est pas
moi c'est vrai donc en premier c'est la
coiffure est prêt dans votre top 3
qu'est ce que vous regardez en 2d puis
revoir 2e 13e mois wen regarde jeu c'est
de savoir si la personne a une
sensibilité lam lam de la personne dame
à la rate et tout ça je regarde la mort
fait au gabon c'est qu'ils sont la pire
de chez eux dans l'est franchement je
regarde la pureté vous regardez quoi
vous le visage les lèvres les dents et
les mains le visage les lèvres quoi le
visage des dents les lèvres les dents et
les mains et la résine voici un scan est
en fait puisque anne seydoux j'espère
que les femmes nous répondrons pas votre
schmitz vous vous regardez quoi delphine
wespiser la can
m
non
je regarde je regarde le visage pour moi
c'est bah oui forcément je regarde le
visage et j'aime bien regarder les
épaules le centre largeur des poils
c'est joli non mais est comme ça c'est
joli à regarder comme castaldi tenez
vous droit vous êtes magnifique 1 mais
qu'elle fait bien souvent ils
s'inquiètent mais il est très très beau
il vieillit très très bien à la basse et
s'ils m'avaient qui s'inquiètent pour
moi je suis moi c'est moi qui ai très
bien que je lève vous des kelly à moi je
regardais cicatrices ouais je regarde
une appendicite appelle la police c'est
magnifique sans rigoler non mais c'est
pour connaître la personne son passé l'a
vécu si elle a eu des blessures quoi
c'est le plus important pour moi car
c'est benali
alors moi le sourire très important un
très beau sourire des belles dents est
alors un truc peut-être un peu bizarre
temps mais les avant bras
ah je croyais des couilles mais vraiment
bras quand un homme remonte ses chemins
et là tout d'un coup la l'avant-bras
devine que ça vous n'en savons pas quand
vous avez des très beaux dans l'eau de
partout alors les yeux
l'éclat dont les yeux une intelligence
humour voilà un peu pas comme ça et les
ongles les ongles très important
maintenant de nickel moi je moi je me
ronge saison a vraiment peur bleue
maintenant on sait avec moi je mets tout
ni angoissé ya pas de budget cité sur
ces huit manches et la maintenant on va
signer pour trois grands déterminé je
mets dans patate chaude et la qualité du
poil la qualité du poil très bien garni
comme vous me regardez quoi les yeux les
yeux tout se passe dans les yeux ah
ouais ouais
aimez vous et vous ou pas les yeux alors
que vous obséder par les pieds des
embauches qui noie ses rares clameur
[Rires]
le monde
dès que ces arts du bois les premiers
rendez vous salle et porto politique sa
j'adore
peter ader des côtes mais les hommes
sont sensibles des pieds justement quand
même regarder les pieds les forçats des
pieds j'ai l'impression que dans 2 jours
vous êtes tracera ta'qali vous êtes
passé just fly à une avant de rappeler
nikov et delphine wespiser si vous
prenez pas de boîte de xanax la sublime
bien un truc assez bizarre et que jamais
regardé chez les hommes c'est le nez et
en particulier les ailes du nez
l'âge d'homme je regarde les albanais
chez les nôtres ont donné voilà c'est
fini
électrodes deuxième appel à l'école on a
tous fait ça
j'ai envoyé les crottes 2 nd oui le
collège le siège avait pas de vie
j'avais des crottes de zen à la place il
était 13h alors oui mais voilà qu'à la
cave
non parce que c'est je t'aime pas ça
fait deux heures qui parle pas on parle
de 3 2 à l'aller on avait cette spéciale
et les yeux les mains et les saints qui
était celui-là ça m est là l on est
gamin j'étais ado doit d'après la police
la mini-trêve frère philippe val et moi
ça c'est regarde chico potes les choses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais moi quand je regarde les sentences
boublil et mon fils
[Applaudissements]